The Descendants franchise is a huge
success and it's filming schedule is
known for being hectic there's more girl
she made me look good so the cast needs
to be ready to go once the cameras start
rolling but to pull that off
you've got to put in some serious work
ahead of time here's how the cast of
descendants three gets ready for their
roles you won't believe how much
training and discipline is involved the
rehearsal process and song record
process fare insane it's really
physically taxing they get into shape so
much work goes into creating the
descendents films screenplays need to be
written songs need to be recorded and
dances need to be choreographed before
stepping foot on a set The Descendants
actors need to get into top shape that
means working out on the daily and
dancing like there's no tomorrow
you need to be able to keep up with your
choreographer and huffing and puffing
after doing a couple of flips and
pirouettes is simply not an option they
get healthy on top of putting in some
serious hours at the gym The Descendants
cast starts preparing themselves for the
camera mini Disney Channel contract
strictly state that the actors cannot
gain or lose weight or alter their
appearances so watering their inner
plant is a must
eating healthy and staying hydrated will
prepare them for their upcoming filming
schedules and who doesn't want to shine
while on camera they practice their
American accents this one may come as a
shock but a few of our favorite
descendants actors aren't actually
American in fact some of their accents
are 100% staged many actors have had to
drop their native accents and dawn on a
new one for the sake of their on-screen
characters and Mitchell hope is one of
them he was born in Melbourne Australia
and has a thick Australian accent so
before getting into King van shoes
Mitchell practices his American accent
for days on end
Thomas Doherty on the other hand is
known for his charming Scottish accent
you know I mean over Kenny Ortega let
him hold on to that one since it fits
his character hairy like a glove or
should we say a hook they dye their hair
The Descendants cast is known for having
very colorful hair especially the
villains but while some of them wear
wigs to achieve their vibrant hair
colors dub Cameron and Sofia Carson wore
wigs that required them to sit for hours
at a time
let the late Cameron boys kick things up
a notch to get ready for his role he
spent six hours in a salon chair dyeing
his hair platinum blonde he totally
rocked this look on and off screen but
by descendant 3 Cameron was ready to put
down the hair dye and bring on the wig
voice training if you want Kenny Ortega
to be impressed by your work ethic you
want to come to the studio prepared so
trading your voice ahead of time is
something the descendants cast
constantly does this way when they're
ready to record their songs their
pitches are perfect and they're hitting
every single note unlike the other
members of the cast booboo Stewart
wasn't exactly known for his singing
abilities so he prepared himself by
taking singing lessons before shooting
the movies but despite being triple
threats themselves even dub Cameron
Sophia Carson and Cameron Boyce made it
a point to sharpen their vocal chords
they study their characters The
Descendants franchise is deeply rooted
in the Disney Princess universe so every
character has a backstory to get into
character the cast studied Disney movies
and drew inspiration from their
on-screen parents when china anne
mcclain found out that she was being
cast as uma daughter of ursula she binge
watched The Little Mermaid 20 times she
did this to study how Ursula moved and
talked so that she could get into
character but she wasn't alone in doing
this nearly everyone in The Descendants
franchise made it a point to study their
characters before filming the movies
they get their feedback before the
Disney Channel green lights a movie they
want to make sure that their script is
perfect but to do that they have to
workshop a couple of different ideas
first their plot lines are constantly
changing and sometimes they like to let
their main actors in on the process dove
Cameron admitted that she was in on the
writing of the plot before descendant
three hit the production stage the main
actors saw the script evolve and even
gave their feedback this gave them
plenty of time to get ready for their
roles dev stated that she's known who
her real father is since the very
beginning they memorized their scripts
this is a given for any actor and it's
one of the most important things an
actor can do to get ready for an
upcoming role once the cast of
descendants gets their script they start
memorizing it and getting into character
every line is accounted for it the MOR
dub knows about the script the more time
she has to develop her character and
this goes for every other cast member -
well it's perfectly normal to forget
your lines now and then no one likes to
work with someone who doesn't come
prepared they try on their costumes if
there's one thing that The Descendants
franchise doesn't skimp out on it's
glamorous outfits they have costume
designer Karis on from Project Runway
working on the cast costumes and
creating the perfect looks takes time to
get ready for their roles The
Descendants cast has to spend time
trying on their new outfit this gives
Kara plenty of time to see what works
and what doesn't and once the main
actors know what their fierce new looks
are all about they can truly start
getting into character that's a wrap on
how the cast of descendants gets ready
for their roles who's your favorite DK
you make sure you get your cut
tell us in the comments for more videos
about your favorite Disney movies and TV
shows subscribe to the things and don't
forget to give us a big thumbs up thanks
for watching we'll catch you later
[Music]